oh I believe oh there's some mud rats
out there that have no genes almost I
feel like like mud rat humans yeah just
people that are just smoking their own
dicks out there who have no real light
like you know what I'm saying like I've
met some people who yeah they're
breathing but that's it really yeah this
idea that we're all created equal
you've never met anybody that's a genius
if you say that I've met some people
that I'm like I talked time ago I'm like
a monkey yeah yeah dude I talked to your
buddy Eddie Bravo and that guy is a real
he's out there he's like a J he's like a
deaf like a deaf Jack Russell almost you
know a deaf Jack Ross yeah cuz once he
gets going you can't Oh Jack Russell
terrier yeah you ever been around one of
those dogs you open the car and then the
next thing you know they're uh yeah
they're like sick yeah well how's he
deaf because you can't get him back like
once he goes you can't you can't get him
back in the car like you're sitting
there honking the horn you can't that
guys out there you know my home you know
I'm talking about make a description
like that Jack Russell terrier that is
hilarious extravagant dude yeah that
means extravagant he's so motivated he
loves conspiracies more than anybody
I've ever met in my life and he thinks
everything is a conspiracy
yeah no no he definitely but then he
gets into it like I don't know it was
fascinating to me how he went from this
like one genre of life to the next and
created a business in each one and kept
moving forward a business yeah he got
like he was a muse he liked music he
started a band you know he liked karate
he started doing you know organized
karate he liked you know what else did
he beat a couple of other businesses I
think he got into a couple of other
things I don't know what the other two
were he lost me a chapter 70 but he'll
hate you were too much information man
it was crazy a lot of people to Google I
was like I want to climb through a black
hole right now dude the other night 2:00
a.m. he says he knows 1:00 a.m. phone
calls coming
you'll get you will get a wall of text
explaining which YouTube video has the
right information which one is set up by
the CIA it used to be like stopping at a
rest area on the interstate that was
like the old Eddie frevo like you'd stop
there and next thing you know you hear
the craziest [ __ ] in the world right and
used to co-star in the background no now
he loves all of it he loves but he gets
out he goes in phases like he gets out
of him for a while
it was really into chemtrails for a
while but man I know you probably won't
admit it but it's pretty obvious
chemtrails are [ __ ] yeah pretty
[ __ ] obvious yeah it's just right
because they can right birthday they can
write happy birthday Rhonda or something
and that's not that just seems like
that's smoke somebody's birthday yeah I
think when they do that they're doing
that like on purpose but the the
chemtrail thing is just it's just
nonsense there's there is some evidence
that they have experimented with
spraying stuff in the sky and they
definitely seed clouds in certain parts
of the world and certain parts of the
country you know they can make it rain
like in its it's Abu Dhabi right where
they make it rain once a week Wow once a
week it's they live in the desert listen
jets up there yeah yeah they send jetson
I think they use something silver iodine
or something like that is that what it
is one of the pilots they spray into the
clouds and somehow or another it makes
it rain you know when a DK when I was
talking about that with that he one
thing I was thinking about was do you
think that there are aliens oh do you
think that robots will get so advanced
that they will like become aware and
what does he say oh I don't know what he
said I guess I'm asking you because he
went off on something else and he didn't
really answer it he said it doesn't get
too much he's more into like the FBI
trying to [ __ ] us over yeah well he told
me in the bathroom after we told no joke
he said he had to be a little bit quiet
because he thinks that some people could
be looking for oh that's so crazy and it
was crazy he said that all hush to us by
the urinals dude he thought that the
government got to me really because I
wasn't in chemtrails chemtrails what did
it he's like she's got it's got to be a
reason here did they do anything to you
no no you swear I
where no one's talked to me about
anything ever
no one said Amen lay off lay off that
Bigfoot talk but what do you say I'm
just saying if you want to know how do i
man is this what are you showing me
Jamie this is the article about the
cloud sitting in Abu Dhabi they know
they use hide Wow hygroscopic salt to
level up the amount of amount of
moisture to generate more rain huh I
could see him doing that dr. habiba
adding that the best season for seeding
is between June and August uh-huh
so something I mean there's there's
blasting salt up into that yes you yeah
they spray [ __ ] and it makes it rain I
find that the moon say we went to the
moon the moon seemed like something
Delta could get to if you really think
about it like you know what I'm saying
Airlines yeah like if they got Southwest
all right I mean little bit shaky on
there some of the people are they're
wearing shorts you know how you get on
I don't trust anybody in shorts
especially at church right but um I'll
say this when you like it's crazy we've
been flying across America for you know
40 50 years now right yeah even more
maybe you know and it seems like it's we
could figure out how to get into space